so
well good afternoon councillors um we're
just past the appointed air
um a meeting is due to start so i'll
declare the meeting open
and welcome you all along to this
particularly important
meeting of the gore district council we
have three apologies today we have an
apology from councillor bulger
councillor grant nick grant and
councillor davis nikki davis
somebody like to move those apologies be
sustained please
moved councilor macphail secondary
councillor mctinnell
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councillors so we're on to
the one item on the agenda and that is
the adoption
of the 2021 to 31 long-term plan
and consultation document and supporting
information that goes with that
so um
in once every three years uh we have a
significant
debate around the direction of council
uh for the next three years and
potentially the next
10 years and this is the the time for
that
councillors will be aware and have been
very involved in
in a number of workshops over the last
12 months looking at some of the
challenges
some of the opportunities that we as a
community have
and just looking at what is the best and
most appropriate way to
to deal with those some of those uh
ones that we would like to drive
ourselves um
some challenges that um being
put one of a better word forced upon us
and and i guess there's no better one
as an example than to mention the three
waters project
and the reformation that is currently um
undergoing and that that space and and
we're not really in a in a very good
situation to be able to ascertain what
that might look like at this point in
time
hopefully over the next month or six
weeks that may well become a whole lot
more clear
and council councils up and down the
country
will understand more about what the
delivery
of three waters looks like but certainly
there's a lot of
other projects on the go and we need to
just work through those
and make sure that we're we're
comfortable with
what the long term plan looks like and
also
particularly comfortable about the way
that we connect with our community
and share the challenges and the
opportunities
because i know councillors will be very
aware
of the busyness of council
at the moment in my time in local
government it's never been
busier than it is right now and we've
got to make sure that we don't
let the business get in the way of the
important
projects and that's what this afternoon
is all about getting us on that
on that journey and taking us through uh
particularly for the next
10 years but we have a document that has
been presented to us
um by the chief executive and i'm going
to ask steve do you want to make any
comment
uh before i open this particular item
hold up
thanks for worship uh just a
clarification that was actually
lornae straith the chief financial
officer that prepared the document
so i don't want to steal renee thunder
she's been front and centre of
the development of the consultation
document
what i would say in just in some
introductory remarks however is that
it has been a very challenging
assignment uh this time around
our auditors have been to be fair very
exacting
in their requirements and we do have
a qualified opinion based around the
um uncertainty and respect of the age
and condition
of our wastewater and water network
to be honest i was a little non-plussed
and bemused by that qualification
given that nothing materially has
changed and arguably we know more about
these assets than
we did three years ago but we find
ourselves with this
qualification and
clearly there's been a very strong
emphasis
on three waters by the auditors who are
tasked with undertaking rigorous
analysis
on behalf of the office of the ordinary
general
and when you juxtapose that with
the reforms that the government has
announced
and the uncertainty as to how long the
council may be in charge of his own
destiny respect to three waters
it makes it for a very challenging
process
that of course and coupled with last
year's
very suppressed rate requirement
i believe that the public at large
probably need to put this
proposed rates increase in context with
the very low rate increase of last year
and when you add those two up you get
somewhere close to
the five percent threshold that we have
self-opposed in our strategy
but again the auditors did insist that
we fully load inflation in year one
and that meant that the rate increase
for the first year the long-term plan
um is about one percent higher than what
the staff
had in the council collectively had
arrived at
but not just my opening remarks i
haven't hope i haven't been too
provocative of your worship and i'll
leave it to
laurnae to run you through the the plan
proper
yeah thank you steve um and my apologies
lornae i should have thrown to you there
uh so i know you've put an awful lot of
time and effort
into um bringing this all together for
us today so
look forward to your comments
thank you your worship um as a chief
executive has mentioned
we it has been quite a long process this
year the process started 12 months ago
and i would like to acknowledge the
support and work that both
council staff and councillors have put
into the workshops and
us arriving to where we have today
the from from where we were four weeks
ago with the last workshop around
financial
financial planning and financial
strategy as the chief executive
mentioned
really disappointed to see that we had
gone from a 7.27
increase to an 8.22 the key factors
around that
are inflation and also which has had an
impact on how we've
looked at our debt repayment so this is
this again this is really disappointing
for us because we'd work hard to
to get a lower
rates increase compared to our fellow
councils
nearby who are all have all have large
increases as well
the one point to note is that the
adoption today is of the consultation
document
so this is what we go out to our public
with for them to talk to us about the
feedback on the issues and what we're
proposing the full adoption of our
10-year plan and a long-term plan does
not occur until the end of june
so there is time to make some small
tweaks and investigate anything we may
we may need to so this is a good
starting point for
for our community initially when we
looked at our workshops we had four
issues four significant issues
we had the change in the rating area to
be
one district we had the water
separation we had the old library
um i guess what we're going to do with
that and also
the royal special fund after
deliberation with the auditors we have
moved the one of our issues into
significant issues going forward rather
than being one we want to consult on
this time and that is the
um the one district one rating area they
were they want us to do some more work
on that before we
before we presented fully to to the
district
so we will endeavor to work on that over
the next three next
12 to 18 months and present it to to the
community before the next ltp
round
i won't go through the issues
individually they've
we have discussed them at length over
several workshops um
they are there the
[Music]
uh as as the chief executive mentioned
about the order report it is qualified
um it is on the condition and age of our
um assets are three waters assets but
it's only on the wastewater and
stormwater
one of the mitigating factors for the
council and the and not knowing the
agent of
assets is the fire that the council
experienced in 1957. this destroyed a
lot of the records that we had around
our assets
and so we have not got the hard evidence
to go back to to give
counts uh give the auditors confidence
in the figures
it's not saying that figures aren't
correct it's just that we don't have the
confidence they haven't got the
hardcore evidence to to back it up
what we are doing to mitigate that
though is that the three waters team
have an extensive programme of
investigation going forward
they it has already started with cctv
investigation
of our pipes so we know that going
forward into the into the future we'll
have a better understanding of what our
assets look like
and and therefore be able to have a more
i guess a more structured renewals
program we'll have a better idea of what
we believe will fail
when
the there's one other small item i
wanted to bring to your attention
and again it was a
result of the auditors delaying some of
their of some of their decisions and
getting back to us
on page two of the memo a couple of my
dates are incorrect because when i had
first drafted it
um we were planning to bring this to you
last week
because of the movements the dates
underneath the distribution
distribution of the consultation
document are incorrect so the accounts
they'll be up on council's website
tomorrow
on the 21st of april and feedback is
open until wednesday the 19th
of may so just a couple of corrections
there
the the normal process for adopting
for adopting the consultation document
is that we need to adopt the stream of
raft of reports first so the financial
strategy the infrastructure strategy
the prospective financial statements uh
respective funding impact statements
significant forecasting assumptions
revenue and financing policy
liability management policy investment
policy and remission of rates policy and
significant engagement policy
so that that is the first step of us
adopting the consultation document and
then
we go into the consultation document
itself
but your worship i'm happy to answer
questions from
councillors look thank you lorna um
just uh for understanding and clarity
can i ask um communications manager
sonia do you just want to outline the
the process of engaging with the
community with our consultation document
what that's going to look like
uh yes certainly through the chair what
we are doing this year
is um sending out uh information with
all the rates notices which go out next
week to alert people the fact that
our 10-year plan consultation document
is available
and open for feedback the document
itself a hard copy the document will be
available
at all our usual points council offices
the library when it reopens
the pool visitor center in the materia
service centre
we'll also um of course have a project
page on our let's talk forum which will
have all the documents including the
consultation document an online
submission or feedback form as well as a
pdf form that people can download if
they wish to do it in hard copy
and of course we'll also carry out
publicity through all our usual channels
that being
the two local radio stations uh the
insign
our social media and antenna so we'll
touch
um digital end and hard copy and
traditional basis
okay thank you for that okay councillors
um questions comments around
the process and what we're what we're
going through
any thoughts counselors would like to
share councilman mcphail
it's just uh just one query regarding
the rating variance
with that inflation adjustment um maybe
more burden than for the ceo but is it
have we struck that before when our
auditors have been through
and uh have had that
like i said worship no that's the first
time i've encountered that
okay so it's uh obviously it's a change
in their practice not our practice
um through your worship normally the
auditors are very um vigilant and we
expect them to be
in relation to inflation adjusting your
figures throughout the duration of the
10-year plan
but in response to the
prevailing economic conditions that were
upon us 12 months ago
we in our first year tried to be as
accurate and as clinical as possible in
terms
of uh calculating what we needed
an inflationary sense for the next 12
months and
the auditor said that that wouldn't cut
the mustard and we had to
load in an allowance for the first
year's figures even though that we were
setting them three months from when
the new year would come into place so
it's the first time that i've
encountered that but
in saying that um it's we would probably
be a lot more exacting
in our calculations this time around
given the
straightened times that we're in and the
need for trying to find
the lowest possible figure known that we
had
a lot of pressure upon us at the get-go
because we had a very low
rate requirement last year
so there would be no change in the fact
that we've got a five percent
set of uh preferable rate adjustment
that we need to increase that because
inflation is going to be included next
time like is it
something we need to look at
incorporating it now that the auditors
now bring that into their
um part of their requirement three
wishes
the auditors were quite happy with years
two two
to ten and they had been inflation
adjusted it's just that we didn't put
the full allowance on inflation in year
one
thinking that we could um navigate our
way through that with a lesser figure
and they weren't happy with that and
asked us to put it back in
and that had that one percent effect on
rates overall
no thank you okay thanks um
councillor hosted your thanks your
worship i guess i
find myself sitting here wondering whose
plan this is in fact
i i think all these others are going too
far like their roles to identify
material risks
so this group and the staff have gone to
a considerable week
to minimise the rating impact on our on
our community
only to have the auditors overall us and
impose a one percent increase to rates
which i find totally ridiculous uh then
to find out that our one district rating
reviews being put on ice by the auditors
it just will
i find it beautiful that's not their
role um
our role was to lead the community not
not an auditor
i think in terms of this one rate
increase for inflation we should make a
real effort to set that aside
and apply it to debt reduction at the
end of the term to try and
support the community and what we're
doing there we may not achieve that
through
inflationary pressures um audit isn't
voluntary it's 1.3
of our rates go to order fees this year
231 000
um it's it's out of line um
and then to qualify the opinion in
relation to the reliability of our
underground assets that are 60 years old
this year
um if we would affect there in a repairs
and maintenance assumption
or employ a group of consultants even to
guide us on that
the rates increase would be double digit
so again
what on earth are the authors thinking
like who do we refer to
it's come from the auditor general can
we go can we go further than that and
get a bit of sense around this
these are the bunch of auditors that
couldn't discover uh company cars being
fortunately sold in dunedin and we're
focusing on
ridiculous assets here so i've got i'm
disappointed i think the staff
have gone to a real effort to get us a
real plan identify the real issues for
our community
it's the other efficiency consultation
now uh let's hear back
but yeah i'd love to hear from the chief
as to where we could go with this uh
this order and probably on in light of
our annual plan
being qualified around customer service
requests which we voice their display
around you look certainly i share the
sentiments you um
you make brett in terms of whose plan is
this
and there are some very tight
restrictions around what councils can do
and can't do
and they seem to be becoming more and
more stringent as time goes on
and i'd have to say that i haven't
experienced although i haven't been had
physical contact with the auditors
myself
the feedback i've had from staff has
been that this has probably been the
most
uh strenuous and probably exhausting
audit process this council's ever
undertaken
and to have that throw up uh an extra
charge that we had gone out of our way
to to minimise is incredibly
disappointing
um i think we should make our feelings
known to the author general
um but i think we also need to be making
our feelings known
um to the the minister of local
government
and and government in general
steve do you want to make any comment to
that
you think you should i would only occur
the concerns it's been the most
difficult
audit process uh since i've been
involved which spans quite a few years
now
and you do and council heist is correct
you do wonder
about the influence of non-elected
non-resident people having on your plan
and it does seem to me that the audit
now has taken on a life of its own
and a license of its own to really wade
into areas where
you've been told well that's that
argument's not good enough or that needs
to be repackaged or reworded
or in the case of one rating error it
backed out and all we wanted to do with
that one rating here is to say well
look um this is a concept we know that
it needs some work but we'd like you to
perhaps
give us some preliminary views and we'll
come back to you in three years with a
firm proposal but the orders said no
that's not
fit for purpose it needs to backed out
put somewhere else in the plan
because they want us to come up with
hard and fast rating examples and we
haven't got to that point just yet
we're somewhere in our thinking but this
is where you are
from what i can ascertain no really good
reason you're being told
what you can put to the people and it
doesn't
it isn't based around um the reliability
of information it's based around a
personal preference as to what is fit
for purpose
in a consultation sense
and that troubles me to be fair and it's
it's i'll take the points you're making
steve
and it's it's not as if the audit
history of this council has been a bad
one
it's been a very good one uh and it's
one that we've been proud of
through the years and look i'm sure that
the result of this audit
and and when it's looked at in hindsight
will will also be good but
did it need to be this stringent
absolutely not in my mind
counselor garden then counselor grant
a couple comments i've got um quite a
few notes
but um the first one was just the um
project and the decision there of
supplying 362 000 for the second stage
of the project
has that been passed by council or has
it just been done in a workshop
there was one question and then just
going on is
on page 77 there's a significant
infrastructure decisions
as a blank page i just um there's
nothing there
so the auditors missed that one and
um
i think then in page 80 uh there's a
decision options two and three and page
eighty
80
about tar ceiling we just need to look
at it
it doesn't actually make sense one has
23 kilometers and the other 22 and the
budget figures are quite different of
1.2 million and 1.5 million
and the other probably major one is
probably going back
further down on page 101 as the
estimates for the
three waters and wastewater of close on
320 million dollars
and it's spread over the 50 years and
the budget it shows
out but in reality is whether that's
ever going to come to fruition
and capacity wise or whether we have the
ability to actually borrow that money to
do their work
and really the auditors probably should
have noted that
and said that you know this council
probably hasn't got that capacity to do
that
and it hasn't been noted and i think it
should be noted
because basically we're just probably
relying on that just relying on that
work been handed over in the
three-wooders
reform um but to actually
no note on it is probably pretty poor so
yeah the assumption they're making
around that is that we'll still be the
owner
in in three years time but
that's yet to be decided uh and nobody
really knows
my point is that it's in there on the
budgets to spend
320 million and we probably haven't got
the capacity to even borrow that money
and that was deliberately driven yeah do
you want to make a comment yesterday
yes um in terms of that uh 123 million
look that's that's the
the infrastructure strategy has to point
out it's 30 years you've got to
state what you believe is the investment
and i've always known that i think i'm
on record saying publicly unless we get
to some
injection of central government funding
issues around the wastewater upgrade
that will be required as a result of any
renewed consent
from violent southland and taking on
board the
national policies to happen on fresh
water
we we are definitely going to need some
helping hand we at the start of the ltp
we made the assumption that for
at least the next three years uh we
would have three waters
in our position um so
we've pursued on that basis but you're
not doing a 10-year plan the
infrastructure here which i think you're
referring to is actually a 30-year one
and even entering the process with
environment southland we are saying well
we believe we need to get to a certain
point it will require a lot of money
to be spent but it's over a generation
not over the next
handful of years um i dare say that
three waters reform
will sort this out one way or the other
in terms of the
meru y center i just
my recollection of that issue is that
the council approved an
increase in its contribution to stage
one
and noted noted that it would need to
increase its investment in stage two but
hence that's why we're now in the
consultation document with the proposal
to put that extra money into stage two
okay council grant
options an option two and three
if you read that through it doesn't
actually make sense
the increase of annual resurfing rates
to 23 kilometers per year
and the budget by 10 from 1.1 million to
1.2 million over 10 years
and then you go down the bottom one
um it's going to go down to 22
kilometers per year increasing the
budget by 10
from 1.5 to 1.27 million
and we won and three percent annually
can we explain that a little bit more
this one
well i think you've you've raised a good
point and
um we need to get some clarification on
that but and we'll put that
aside until later in the meeting and
just
carry on so counselor grant
thank you worship um i'd just like to
reiterate councillor heisted's
remarks about the audit
um who actually audits the auditor
is there an audit of the auditor is that
the order of the general's office
is it their job to do that and if we
disagree with them
i mean why don't we can we do a test
case against this
i mean obviously if it's not going to
cost us thousands and thousands of
dollars but just say come on you know
i don't think we should go hard at this
because
as council high students said the staff
has done a great job
of bringing this to this document
to here and we were trying to keep the
rates as low as possible and all of a
sudden
uh is it the same audit team as we have
been using
for over the years or is it a new water
office or is it someone
walking in trying to stamp their foot
it's it's the auditor that we've been
allocated
by the auditor general's office and that
personnel is different to what it has
been in the past
but that in their terms that's
irrelevant to personnel should be
irrelevant
yeah do you take the point to make um
um dixon and then council hostage you
want to make a comment
yeah um three worship i was just
wondering if any other council is going
through their long-term plan and having
the same
issues and whether um
the local body government new zealand
is picking up on this with the
government
you know that that same issue has been
raised by a number of councils
and as it has been in the past and
and i know that local government new
zealand have uh petitioned
the audit over the years and um
generally the answer is the audit is
what the audit is
and we're there to do a job and this is
the job that we're doing
we see some significant risks in this
sector
and there's a lot of change happening in
this sector so we want to make sure that
everything is right
and and i have no no qualms with that at
all i think that that is right
but when it gets to the point of costing
the average rate payer um a significant
amount of money then i do ask that
question
so certainly making the point to the
order general
is an important one um but the
in the last year 18 months there has
been a new auditor general
and that is and he has a slightly
different
take on life and i guess that's possibly
where this is coming from
um council have said
yeah thank you worship just just a
comment around a council garden's
question around stage two
of the arts and heritage precinct i
think that was a deliberate decision of
the council
to get that into the plan to get some
meaningful feedback
on stage two in terms of its timing and
costs
and just back to this one rating
review you know a system desperate
desperately needs
simplified and if you look at the three
waters reform and the funding approach
taken there it's very much a one rating
approach it would seem or one invoicing
approach as it may be
so i guess the question to achieve
exactly is if we don't proceed
with consulting on that now are we three
years away the next lgp before we can
meaningfully
engage with the community on that
structure so if that is the case what
can we do to bring that
back into life uh through your worship i
think what we can do
is uh step it out over a three-year
period so that we can
perhaps reveal some of our thinking in
next year's annual plan
um and then with the ability to get some
feedback and refine that thinking
and possibly the year after and then
have a final model
in the ltp in three years time
because it's now in the consultation
document that's a concept that we
intend to develop so i think we can
actually publish our thinking
over the next couple of years and annual
plans
okay um other comments or questions
you're pointing at someone oh sorry
hello i
missed you yeah thank you you worship
through your worship um
there's one of councillor guarding's
comments that i'd like to address
and it was around the affordability um
that was a discussion that we had
with the auditors and again it was an
area of disagreement between ourselves
and the auditors
their argument is that we have the
ability to rate higher than our five
percent self-imposed cap
that it is our decision to have the
self-imposed cabin though
therefore we can move that and hence
rate our rate has even higher
the other the other argument was that we
can become a
credit rated council and borrow up to
250 percent of our revenue
and again i know that having having
having worked here the council
is mindful of our constituents of our
rate payers and of trying to ease the
burden on them
so this is this is again something that
we disagreed with
uh with them on and you'll see notes
throughout the consultation documents
saying that there are avenues for us to
um to fund some of these some of these
activities
but we were we did put our foot down
on on that and said we do not want to
exceed our
our south and post limits for a reason
for a very very good reason
okay council garden did you want to make
a comment
okay councillor hosted
sorry to go again your worship but the
um just a question around the liability
management policy
um i believe personally that audit and
risk need to have another look at this
we i realize we have to adopt it tonight
to move forward but
can we make a technical submission at a
future date
to make the amendment and i'm referring
to the interest rate bans
um you know the the market has changed
significantly since we last
did that and our hedging policy is
forcing our advisors to advise us to
take positions that i
don't think are necessarily right
personal view but it would be great to
get all the rest have a look at that
certainly the ability for a technical
submission would be there
uh absolutely and just in terms of
accountability of the order general the
auditor general is ultimately
accountable to parliament so that that's
that's who he reports to he doesn't
report to us or anybody else
it is parliament
okay um other questions comments
and i know over the next little while
there'll be a lot of debate
a lot of interest in this document and
in council will need to
determine its way forward
when we get to the point of making
adopting
the the long-term plan
but the role tonight really is to adopt
the consultation document
to make sure that we can get that out
and engage the public
so is there any other particular
questions at this point
john just at page 77 um with the
significant infrastructure decisions
there's nothing there just is this me to
be something there or is it just a
blank laura do you want to make a way to
that
uh your worship i'll throw that to my uh
counterpart the general manager of
infrastructure governance infrastructure
strategy
um on page 77 ramesh there's a
figure 2 is significant infrastructure
decisions
there's nothing there so it's blank
in infrastructure strategy the document
it just says about significant
infrastructure decisions i don't know
which report has been
i was not party to this report okay so
look i think steve can probably
yell uh your worship i i don't have the
exact answer i can see that certainly
the wording on those two options um is a
little askew
and there will be a schedule of
significant projects
what i suggest we do because mr standard
is not here
is that you adopt the strategy
uh subject to the wording changed
in options two and three on what was my
page 80
in the electronic agenda and that the
schedule is provided
and that can also be provided via a
technical submission although
that would be only for the record my
strongest recommendation is that we put
it into the strategy proper
so it's out there for the people to note
right from the get-go
um so i i've actually read the strategy
but
um i'm pretty sure the version i read
didn't have a blank page i would have
asked a question
looking at the document further this is
a full meeting issue it's purely
automatic issues on the next page
so what it's referring to is on the next
page
okay
all right thank you for that
there's a format 78 is issues 77 as
decision decisions
so you you so lunai you're saying that
this is a
simply a formatting issue and will be
reflected
in the changes going forward yes we'll
we'll have a look and make sure to see
whether that's what it is
um i will refer to the general manager
of infrastructure and
and we will work through this together
too okay right okay
council read thank you your worship
um i'd just like to make mention of the
rates
remission of rates policy i know that
there'll be some
concern in the community given the rate
increase but
i just would encourage the rate payers
to investigate the
rates rebate scheme and not to be put
off by the fact that it does actually
have a
limited amount that you qualify for
because it is a sliding scale and
people can actually get a partial offset
of rates
as well so i think that's important
going forward as well
okay thank you yeah and like it's always
an
important factor that should be taken
into account and and i'm not
i stand to be corrected here but my
understanding is we've never really
had a community that's taken that to its
fullest extent
so um if you think you may or if the
residents think that they may
uh qualify for some sort of remission
then it's pretty important that they ask
the question
of of counsel and there will be some
user-friendly staff available to to work
through that
and and i know that it may be a
challenge for some people
around privacy but certainly our
practice in the past is to make sure
that
it is a absolute private conversation
with an individual
of the staff and that goes no further
but they can give the
the the resident a a good stare on what
is the best deal for them
in terms of remission thank you worship
but also note that the our
communications officer
roundabout rate time does always have
something and it's also
on our council facebook page not
facebook sorry just the council
website website yeah okay
right hey so any other particular issues
that councillors want to raise at this
point in time
and i think we we need to bear in mind
the potential formatting issue
around the major projects
in any resolution we pass now
but i do have an assurance that that
will be sorted
uh pretty quickly uh any other issues
councillors
wish to make okay okay so we're
i think we're at that point then when we
do need to
um adopt the consultation document
um and the supporting information
so that we can engage with our community
and we we have a recommendation there
that i think covers
all of those issues is that right
okay right so
would some somebody like to
move that recommendation please so we
can engage
councillor heisted secondary councillor
reed thank you
is there any um discussion on that
does not i'm going to put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councillors this is a
significant
step in the life of this council and and
also in the life of councils yet to come
so it is it is very important that um
a conversation uh with the community is
as undertaken
in a in a as a constructive manner as
possible
and that we get to the point uh when we
adopt this long-term plan
that it is going to serve the best
interests in the long term
of this community so thank you
councillors
my understanding is there is no further
business to be transacted
today this was a one item agenda so
thank you for your attendance thank you
for your input
and declare the meeting closed thank you